hey let's talk about Twitter twitter has
been a bigger and bigger sort of factor
in American politics over the last two
years and the President of the United
States the current one not the prior one
has been known to brag like a
fourteen-year-old about how many social
media followers he has it's sort of like
a badge of honor which is a weird badge
of honor for a 70 year old billionaire
but fine Twitter followers are a badge
of honor for Donald Trump he has 31
million followers on his Twitter account
laughably it turns out that roughly half
of those Twitter followers are fake it's
widely known that you can buy Twitter
followers fake twitter accounts are
readily created easily bought and sold
in large numbers it's a common marketing
technique anyone can do it just type
into Google by Twitter followers you'll
have pages and pages of places where you
can very cheaply by Twitter followers
for example look at comedian Joe
Mandy's Twitter page where he has a
million followers and his profile
description says Twitter is trash
Facebook's of the devil I bought a
million followers for like $400 none of
this matters Antarctica is melting this
weekend Donald Trump's Twitter page saw
a major spike in new followers but upon
very superficial inspection many of
those new followers appear to be fake if
you just browse through Trump's Twitter
followers which anyone can do you just
click on the number of followers and you
start paging through Trump's followers a
ton of them are accounts with no
pictures and no tweets ever which is a
typical thing of fake and and sort of
automatically created accounts if you
run Donald Trump's Twitter handle
through an analyzer that uses algorithms
to determine the authenticity of one's
Twitter followers there's a site for
example called Twitter audit com you
find that only about 51% of Donald
Trump's Twitter followers are real as
you can see here on screen a recent
estimate from Twitter audit estimates
that fifteen point nine million of
trumps followers are real and fifteen
million of Donald Trump's Twitter
followers are fake I wanted to test the
accuracy of this site so I entered the
name of Joe
Andy's Twitter account on the website
again Joe Mande admits that he bought a
million followers or some significant
number of them and indeed the Twitter
audit comm report says 7% of Joe Mandy's
Twitter followers are real the other 93%
or fake and as another test I put my own
Twitter account in there Dee Pakman I've
never bought Twitter followers and it
came up saying that 94% of my followers
are real which makes sense because there
are lots of spam accounts that just
follow a ton of people without you
buying them old accounts that have no
recent activity that the algorithm might
be seen as a sort of fake follower so it
does appear that this is an accurate
website Twitter audit com and people
have known this about Trump's Twitter
account for a long time but what really
is interesting is that the percentage of
his followers that are fake is
increasing even while he's President of
the United States in January 68% of
Trump's followers were reportedly real
on Twitter that's now down to 51% do you
understand what that means Pat that
means that the President of the United
States considers Twitter followers an
important enough thing that while
President he or someone designated by
him is still buying fake followers on
Twitter you know this is really
concerning for me because I follow
Donald Trump on Twitter because I want
to keep up with his antics the color
Bethy tweets and all that and now that I
know that I have a 50/50 shot at being
fake it's a real existential crisis for
me I completely agree with you it is a
disgrace and this is the social media
version of the inauguration crowd size
lies and what purpose could this serve
beside besides trying to boost Trump's
image and vanity this is the type of
thing that matters to Trump and it still
matters even when he's president Donald
Trump is tweeting cops fe2 millions of
fake followers do you know what I love
about this - he only ranks a 34th on the
all-time list of Twitter followers do
you know who comes at it and that number
third with 89 million followers Barack
Obama is that right yes
well you know what we didn't do we
didn't run
and I'm just going to try to do this
let's see if I can run Barack Obama
through Twitter audit comm I mean I
wonder what percentage of his followers
come up is real or fake here happening
live
he's Barack Obama on Twitter right I
think interesting according to this only
65% of Barack Obama's followers are real
Wow geez that is a revelation right
groundbreaking story what what do we
make of that so well maybe the real
story is Trump only has slightly more
fake followers than Barack Obama on
Twitter I mean if we if we believe that
this is an accurate website then that
does not paint particularly well for
Barack Obama the only two people with
more followers than Barack Obama is Katy
Perry and Justin Bieber I wonder how
they would rank yeah well you know we
know that there's a lot of believers out
there and I don't know I think that they
did run those through and Justin Bieber
came up with a high percentage of real
real followers anyway what's the point
here the point is Donald Trump really
cares even as president of the United
States about the number of followers
that he has on Twitter just like he
cared on day one he becomes president
right he ascends to the throne of the
presidency and he talks about the number
of people that attended his inauguration
it's weird it's weird